"OUTNUMBERED OVER TIME."
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE STORY OF AMERICAN DECLINE IS
A STORY OF AN INCOMPETENT RULING
CLASS.
WE WILL HEAR MANY SELF-SERVING
EXPLANATIONS FOR IT BUT THE
TRUTH IS IT’S THAT SIMPLE.
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE INHERITED
AN INDUSTRIAL SUPERPOWER AND IN
A LITTLE MORE OF A GENERATION
THAT SQUANDERED ALL OF IT.
THEY EXCHANGED SHORT-TERM
PROFITS, BIGGER VACATION HOMES,
CHEAPER HOUSEHOLD HELP.
THEY BUILT WHAT THEY DID NOT
BUILD.
THEY IMPORTED A SURF CLASS TO
DRIVE DOWN WAGES AND CRIPPLED
THE MIDDLE CLASS WHILE DOING IT.
THEY HAD TRILLIONS IN UNPAYABLE
DEBT, TURN THE FINEST
UNIVERSITIES OF THE WORLD INTO A
JOKE.
THEY WATCH FROM THEIR DECADENT
LITTLE BUBBLES OF AFFLUENCE AS
FAMILY, FAITH, PUBLIC DECENCY
DIED IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEY
LAUGHED BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T
CARE.
HOW PEOPLE THIS AWFUL WOUND UP
IN CHARGE OF A NATION AS GREAT
AS OURS IS A QUESTION HISTORIANS
WILL HAVE TO ANSWER, AND THEY
WILL SOMEDAY.
AT THIS POINT, THE POPULATION
HAS GROWN TIRED OF IT.
DONALD TRUMP ELECTION IS ONE
CLEAR SIGN OF THAT.
THE RISE OF BERNIE SANDERS IS
ANOTHER.
THE RULING CLASS IN OTHER WORDS
IS LOSING ITS GRIP ON POWER AND
THEY CAN FEEL IT.
THEY CAN SMELL IT.
IT TERRIFIES THEM.
THE FIRST RESPONSE WAS DENIAL,
IT ALWAYS IS FOR THE RETREAT
INTO FANTASY.
WHY CAN’T WE JUST ELECT
JOE BIDEN AND MAKE IT 2009
AGAIN.
WHEN IT DIDN’T WORK, THEY
REVERTED TO THEIR GOVERNING
INSTINCT WHICH IS
AUTHORITARIANISM FOR THEY STOP
CONVINCING THE PUBLIC OF
ANYTHING AND INSTEAD DECIDED TO
SCARE THEM.
FEAR FOR OLD ARE EASIER TO
CONTROL.
YOU SAW IT IN THE FRONT PAGE,
"NEW YORK TIMES," LAWMAKERS
WARNING THAT RUSSIA IS MEDDLING
TO HELP ELECT TRUMP.
INSIDE THE STORY, IT WAS ENOUGH
TO ALERT THE AND CABLE NEWS,
TIME TO DO THEIR JOB NOW AND
ALWAYS WHICH IS TO RUN
INTERFERENCE FOR THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE FOLLOWING
CLIP, MOST PEOPLE IN TELEVISION
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING EVEN AS THEY ARE SAYING
IT, THEY ARE READING THE SCRIPT
WRITTEN FOR THEM BY SOME
23-YEAR-OLD WOMEN STUDIES MAJOR
FROM LESLIE AND WHO MAKES LESS
THAN THEY DO.
TRY NOT TO JUDGE THEM TO
PARTIALLY.
>> DONALD TRUMP DESPERATELY
TRYING TO KEEP THAT MATTER
SECRET.
>> IF THE RUSSIANS ARE ATTACKING
OUR ELECTION PROCESSES AND DOING
SO TO BENEFIT DONALD TRUMP, I
THINK THE PRESIDENT WELCOMES IT,
WANTS IT.
>> AS BAD AS IT IS THE RUSSIANS
ARE BACK AT IT, TRYING TO HELP
TRUMP GET ELECTED, IT’S FAR
WORSE THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS TRYING TO COVER
IT UP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A RUSSIAN
OPERATIVE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE DESCRIPTION
OF A BAD HOLLYWOOD SCREENPLAY
BUT IT IS REAL.
IT IS VLADIMIR PUTIN’S GREATEST
ACHIEVEMENT.
THIS IS ONE OF ONE OF THE SHOCKI
DAYS IF YOU RETAIN THE CAPACITY
TO BE SHOCKED IN THE TRUMP ERA,
THE TRUMP REGIME, WHICH MAY
BETTER BE LABELED AS THE
TRUMP-PUTIN REGIME.
>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES HAS COLLUDED WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO STEAL THE
ELECTION BUT NOT THE LAST ONE,
NOT THIS ONE, BUT THIS ONE IN
THE NEXT ONE TOO.
THE PUBLIC DOES NOT SEEM
ESPECIALLY AFRAID OF.
MAYBE THEY’VE HEARD IT BEFORE
FROM SOMEWHERE.
THE LACK OF PANIC IS DEEPLY
DISTRESSING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHICH IS COUNTING ON
ANOTHER RED SCARE SOMETIME
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER.
BRIAN WILLIAMS, TRUSTEE BRIAN
WILLIAMS STEPPED INTO SCHOOL IN
AMERICA NOT BEING MORE
TERRIFIED.
>> WE BEGIN THAT FUNERAL
SERVICES PENDING THE DEATH OF
OUTRAGE, OFFICIALLY DEAD AT
ITS CLOSE RELATIVE, APATHY,
SURVIVES AND IS THRIVING.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
SCREW YOU, AMERICA.
YOU OUGHT TO BE FALLING FOR IT A
SECOND TIME.
HOW DARE YOU.
YOU CAN SEE THE FRUSTRATION ON
THEIR FACES.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU MIGHT
THINK THEY WOULD COME UP WITH A
NEW HOAX OCCASIONALLY.
WHY THEY CANNOT INVENT ARGENTINE
SAPPERS, SOMETHING INTERESTING.
NO, LIKE A ROBOT VACUUM CLEANERS
STUCK CARVING CIRCLES UNDER A
CHAIR, THEY ARE GOING TO DO THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER UNTIL
THE BATTERIES RUN OUT.
NOW THEY ARE TRYING IT ON BERNIE
BERNIE.
>> YOU ASKED THE QUESTION, WOULD
YOU WANT TRUMP OVER
BERNIE SANDERS?
BERNIE SANDERS A DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST, IDEOLOGICALLY INTO
THE WITH THE OLD RUSSIA, ANYWAY,
AND A
REMEMBER, THE RUSSIANS DID
FAVORITE BERNIE SANDERS IN THE
PRIMARY 2015 OVER
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Tucker: BERNIE SANDERS?
HE’S A PUTIN STOOGE QUESTION
MIKE I THOUGHT HE WAS A BREZHNEV
STOOGE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
THAT "BERNIE SANDERS BRIEFED BY
U.S. OFFICIALS THAT RUSSIA IS
TRYING TO HELP HIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN."
HE LEARNED ABOUT IT WEEKS AGO
BUT THE SANDERS CAMPAIGN NEVER
LEAKED THE STORY.
ON THE EVE OF THE NEVADA
CAUCUSES, SOMEONE IN THE
SO-CALLED INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
DID LEAK IT.
AS THEY REPEATEDLY LEAK
SELECTIVE INFORMATION IN AN
EFFORT TO DERAIL DONALD TRUMP
WHOSE POLICIES THEY AGREE WITH
THEY’LL MAKE WITH
DISAGREE WITH.
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM IS IN FACT
UNDER ATTACK.
THAT MUCH IS TRUE.
BUT IT’S NOT THE RUSSIANS
ATTACKING IT, NOT EVEN THE
CHINESE.
IT’S BEING ATTACKED BY OUR ONLY
RULING CLASS FOR THEY ARE
UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY.
IF THEY LET VOTERS DECIDE WHERE
TO GO NEXT, THEY’D BE OUT OF A
JOB TOMORROW BECAUSE THEY’VE